so about one third of this film takes
place in that car have either of you
ever acted in such a confined space for
such a long period of time in one film I
think it was essential to the plot that
we were pulled together in such intimate
circumstances but the short answers your
question is no no but it is essential
and part of the journey of getting this
film made well we'll get to that but is
so much of it takes place in a car and
it is it is a strike against a film it
is very difficult but these days I feel
like if I'm watching mad men or
something and they're in a car it's even
though i love madman it's clear that
they're not actually on the road there
in a green screen somewhere what are the
specific challenges with doing it for
real uh me driving that's my last
driving I you know I was born and raised
in the great city of New Orleans and my
father taught me to drive at 16 but as
I'm now in New York or I've lived in New
York for 30 years and I have lost my
ability to drive but this extraordinary
man an actor had to trust that I would
that I would be able to transport him
he'd like art and life merged in odd and
precarious ways but my driving skills
slowly came back because I had this
amazing instructor just before we came
on we were talking about Jon Favreau my
friend who appeared in the lovely film
the chef he is cooking while he well
he's performing he's cooking there is
there something very liberating to the
actor to be given an action whilst
they're acting it frees you although you
know driving in New York's not exactly
liberating but it does it does change
don't you agree it changes the before it
oh yes the fact that we were that it was
real it was true we were not towed there
was maybe one scene when we had a tow
truck but for the most part it was what
you saw was real driving I love the
moment
there's these emotional passengers in in
the cabs you know and it makes me think
in your preparation for this or
conversations with people did you hear
stories from drivers about interesting
moments they had where their passengers
broke down or too much information kind
of moments the Tevye story I did hear
when we were shooting that lovely scene
are on the broad boardwalk with with the
ice cream that a gentleman was kind
enough to say that off straight after
the catastrophic 911 seek tak cab
drivers in New York turned all their
meters off and and wound down their
windows and gently said two people who
were obviously terribly distressed where
do you want to go whom you want to find
I'll take you there that was the first
gesture they made I also heard during
some some times of flood in in New
Orleans that it was the Sikhs who
organized the Food Kitchen that's the
Sikh way I've learned I've learned that
is the sequa Patricia I was going
through the notes that I had kind of
scribbled down when I was watching the
film a few weeks ago and there's one
scene where Jake Webber's character is
breaking this news to you and leaving
you and the three words I wrote down
were anger hurt and discussed because
though that's what I felt coming from
you and to do all three of those
simultaneously while straddling Jake
women yeah right but in a very tight
skirt no I mean that's one of the
reasons I've loved this story and the
script is you know the the pathos and
the humor air in a flash and in a moment
in both of our characters and by all of
these scenes and in a moment
I I wanted to do that scene justice
because I knew I had to go a thousand
places and in and I didn't want to miss
any of the colors I wanted to do the
scene justice I wanted to do the writing
justice I wanted to be but I had the
great jake weber their present he's such
a fine actor beautiful actor and
Isabelle croisette as the operator just
right there to catch it all and she
really she has a beautiful organic way
of working and you just she just starts
to roll the camera she gives you some
perimeters and then she just lets it fly
and then she you not you're never sure
where the camera is so there's a certain
truth that could really live because
you're not aware of an angle and a
certain moment as actors were often
sometimes a director wants a certain
moment I think Isabel just wants the
whole thing and so it was um it was it
was a very difficult day to shoot but it
was a very beautiful scene so I hope it
mr. Ben I think back to everything from
Bugsy to sexy beasts to Simon v's and
fall to Gandhi to this I can't name
another actor whose body of work crosses
ethnicities so seamlessly like you do
there's no one else i can think of
is that something that you embraced very
early on in your acting career is it
something you came to appreciate about
your acting later on I I hope that I'm a
storyteller by vocation and I do i do
think that storytelling is very healing
and I do think that us as storytellers
are quite crucial to the survival of the
tribe are human tribe and therefore I
think that both patrician I would agree
that we are immensely curious about
others that that we collect information
from others so aside from being part
Indian part English part Jewish I I
don't think it's the DNA because I have
siblings who are very very different
from me so I think fortunately I imbibe
soak in by osmosis the human dance and
I'm privileged to be able to sing my
song at the same time it's a wonderful
position to be in and I'm eternally
grateful sir ben when you think back to
being on the set so this is a film that
as Patricia said based on a essay
written by a woman your screenwriters a
woman your director is a woman who was
also the camera operator of course the
editor after the fact Alma was was a
woman what was it like for you all of
that female energy around that cannot be
a typical everyday experience it makes
me feel immensely secure because the
female I behind the camera is immensely
skilled celebrating two very important
things that the actor tries to use as
currency but sometimes is ignored male
vulnerability and male tenderness and
both those qualities are magnificent
masculine qualities they're not the ones
that immediately come to mind but with
but with Isabelle's observation loving
observations
you it allows me to be vulnerable as an
actor and I use that as a great asset
speaking of vulnerability Patricia was
just saying that when you have those
remarkable moments on screen you have to
metabolize everything into acting and
she used a story with Dana a few minutes
before that happened I was the receiving
end of racial abuse although it was
translated for me later by my very
regretful colleagues on the set you know
I'm really sorry to tell you this but
somebody shouted something I knew
there's something had happened while we
were shooting and I in the parking lot
before that scene it was just before
this just before the scene and somebody
yelled at my character darwan singh he
should be buying a [ __ ] camel not a
[ __ ] car and and that was translated
to me but honestly you have to use
everything no matter how regretful the
incident or how beautiful you can't
actually sift out the light from the
shade you have to sort of twine them
together as black and white threads
black and silver threads is the great
poet said and and use them but i wanted
to dispatch drew all the females is the
female energy and talent and this and
that yes it is a it's an essay written
by a woman adapted by a woman directed
by a woman edited by a woman produced by
a woman and none of us and we're all 45
and up maybe even 50 enough it's an
argument that speaks for itself you know
now obviously it sounds like you all
were on the same page it sounds like
broadgreen pictures on the same page
releasing this so I don't think this
ever and yes remarkable men coming in
and right making this film happen Daniel
hemming and and and Gabriel haven't
incredible they were our saviors they
you know and the fact that they are they
are these two young men
who chose to make a movie they were just
beginning they could have made anything
they could have made something hot sexy
they know where's hot was their debut
but um but but they they chose to make
this this beautiful film about two
middle-aged people in a car a sinky
little car in New York City and so I'm
their incredible men and I'm forever
thankful to them what would have
happened if one of the potential money
people had come to you and your producer
Dana and said I'm interested but I want
them to get together oh no we had many
people come to us with money that wanted
this or change that do you have to drive
around in the car well no yes we're just
okay yet let's just take out all the
cursor we can just simulate them do we
have to drive around you know we had KY
oh he would not believe the things that
people said if we changed they would
make it but a very different mom it was
but the beauty of Gabriel and Daniel
Hammond is they loved the film they knew
the power of the fail you know they they
loved it for exactly what it was and
they wanted to make this movie and they
knew it and let me finish with one last
question for both of you how has this
whole process of making this film
changed the way you view New York City I
am getting more and more fond of New
York City I've known it for many years I
and I I find it's she's a character in
the film basically I have to say she'd
under well with all the women of this
film yeah I love it I don't know I'm I
well I yes I mean I've become a new
yorker which is fabulous you know and I
realized I could I have a profound love
for the city of New York and and it only
deepened in the process of shooting this
film